hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that the just ended uh from
the feed a candidate's tournament
2021 uh it's an issuer versus wang khao
and uh well best just dive straight into
it and uh see
see what's happening so gary with the
white pieces opens
with d4 we have knight to f6 by hal
c4 we have e6 knight to f3 and now
d5 so just striking in the center in the
uh casual queens gambit declined
and g3 geary opts for the catalan
opening with bishop to e7
and the bishop to g2 now so this is all
very very standard stuff we have
castle's castles
and d captures on c for another a very
uh natural movie in the classical lion
of the catalan
queen to c2 preparing to win back the
pawn with queen captures on c4 and this
is uh
always allowed with a6 a4 stopping b5
and now
bishop to d7 we have queen captures on
c4
and now bishop to c6 countering white
slight square bishop
and here gary goes for bishop to f4
which puts additional pressure on c7
so for the moment black cannot move this
bishop
and bishop to d6 now now offering a
trade of dark square bishops here but
instead of trading
uh geary just continues development uh
we have knight to c3 and now black has
uh an option he can capture on f4 and
double white's uh
pawns here uh but it's actually not a
problem uh how goes for this we have
captures captures and now
with these two pawns nicely placed on f4
and d4 gary has an excellent outpost for
his knight on e5
so here we have a5 uh now making room
for the knight so you can bring the
knight over to a6
and e3 strengthening uh the center a
little bit also adding protection to
this
f4 pawn before uh getting this knight to
this e5
outpost uh and now comes knights the a6
and again this is not a new move uh it
has been reached uh
not many times but uh several times and
more notable games uh
uh wesley still defeated david navarra
in this exact same position and also
uh uh vastly vancouver defeated
dominguez perez
uh but here we have knight the e5 in
those games uh
uh rook eight the c1 and king the h1
were played
but here we have knight the e5 and it is
now only as of move 14
uh that we have a completely new game so
it is giri who
is uh well perhaps has taken uh taken
how uh by surprise
uh so here uh the c6 bishop is attacked
three times and you should
definitely do something about this so
how captures we have captures captures
and now
c6 uh now just solidifying the the
position here
and the h3 and this is a really weird
move that uh
no one really knows what it does sort of
probably a deep
engine preparation move by geary here
and
okay one thing we we can say say for
sure that it kind of takes away the g4
square from this knight but other than
that
uh it's hard to say what uh what this
move uh
actually does but okay uh we'll see what
happens so here we have queen to b6
going after this b2 pawn and the queen
back to e2 now defending the pawn
uh we have c5 striking in the center
black uh
that definitely makes sense uh and now
rook f2d1
uh we have c captures on d4 rook
captures on d4
now you can double up on the d file if
if black allows it
and rook a to d8 of course not allowing
this doubling of rooks we have rook
captures
and now while rook capture seems to be
the way to go it's actually not if you
go rook captures here
yes you bring a rook to the nice open d
file queen b5 is a problem for black
here
because you either trade and after
captures captures you have to move the
knight and once you move the knight
white picks up the a5 pawn
or after queen to b5 you're going to
play something like move the queen let's
say queen to c7
and then pretty much the same thing
happens you're just going to play knight
to c4
and good luck defending this pawn on a5
so instead instead of this uh normal
looking rook capture 78 we have queen
capture 78
and now rook to d1 it is giri who wins
the the a5
the d file for his rook so queen to a8
preparing some very nasty b5 ideas
opening up a discovery to the white king
so king to g1
and now knight to b4 but now uh giri
does bring the queen over to b5 so queen
to b5
uh and now knight beat the d5 so get
sorry uh knight b to d5 offering a trade
of knights and geary
very happily does so because if this
knight ever moves you gain control of
the d7 square
and this is very important for for white
so we have knight captures knight
captures and now
shifting the rook to c1 so uh what can
you do here uh it's a
it's a very nice position the the c file
is open uh for the white rook and you
can do
really a lot of rook lifting here
problem is if you go for something like
rook the c8
the counterweights rook along the c file
you can just
capture it and uh well win the a5 pawn
there's also that so you can't really
go for that normal move we have h6 here
creating some breeding room for the king
because
you do have back rank issues here so
queen to d7
now there's again there's pressure on
this pawn here and
of course you cannot move the rook away
from f8 so knight to f6
pushing the queen back and now queen to
d6
uh we have g6 and now comes b3
uh you should always consider moves like
knight captures on g6 and of course
anisha has considered this
for example captures captures in check
and now king moves
of course you don't move somewhere to
allow this rook to come up with check
but for example if king h8 rook the c7
it looks very scary imagine something
like this happening but it's not
black can just play queen to e8 and now
you either trade queens or white moves
the queen you can pick up the a4 pawn so
black should hold this in a in a blizz
game or in a bullet game you don't think
twice about doing this but for a
classical game in the candidates
tournament maybe it's a bit
too much and it's not like you don't
have any options here if this was your
last resort of course you would maybe do
this
but since it's it's not guilty just uh
place it slow with b3
uh we have h5 and now king to h2
improving the position of the king a
little bit king to g7 black does the
same
and now queen to d4 saying that if you
move this knight then you're gonna be in
a lot of trouble uh but instead of queen
to d4 also ideas like maybe queen to b6
were possible
with the idea of shifting the rook over
to c7 with
a lot of pressure uh and only then if
for example black tries to kick away or
queen maybe then queen to d4
with the same idea but okay uh it's uh
gears preparation he knows best we have
queen to d4
and rook to d8 now chasing the queen
away
queen to b2 remaining on this long
diagonal and now
queen to b8 not preparing if white plays
a slow move you can play some like b6 or
even b5 maybe try and trade some pawns
on the queen side
so gear replaced b for uh before black
and now
a captures on b4 now you don't recapture
rather you go rook to c4
preparing to capture with the rook and
then go after the b7 pawn
so b3 trying to get the gear to capture
with the queen
but rook to be for not not allowing this
and now it's a it's a very dangerous
position for black black really doesn't
have all that many great moves
uh one thing you could do is play
something like queen to d6 allow the
grabbing of the b
pawn and then go queen to d2 try maybe
something like this and then if king to
g2
you're gonna go king g8 uh and now after
let's say row captures on b7 you're
gonna bring the the knight over here
uh pressure the the f2 pawn and here
white would have to trade queens
and then you trade for example captures
captures play rook a8 and
then you play this end game being down
upon it's uh hard to say if uh
if this is a draw if if white can maybe
push for a win
uh either way black would really get
tortured here for
for quite a while so instead uh howard
tries uh
queen to a7 tries to go after the a4
pawn if rook captures and b7 happens
but this actually loses terribly so feel
free to pause the video and win this
game for a niche
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh gobbling up
that b3 pawn
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show both queen captures uh
and the rook captures is all right
however rook captures is is
uh the best uh so rook capturism b3 was
played
and now the problem is you don't really
have a good move this is happening
whether you like it or not
if you play something like rook here
then the problem is just knight d7
you you should never forget about this
knight being unable to move
so this would just be a straight out
losing for black so instead after rook
captures on b3
uh how played queen captures on a4 but
this doesn't help rook captures on b7
now putting pressure on the f7 pawn
uh and here again you cannot defend if
rook here the same idea
wins the knight is pinned there's no
defending this night so after rook
captures on b7 we have rooked the queen
to e8
now saying that okay uh if you want you
can try giving up
to rook and knight for a queen i will
very gladly accept this
and try and hold this but gary says
there is no need to rush things i can
just play rook to a7 or rook to c7
uh either either is fine and then triple
my
uh well threat on the f7 pawn
here rook to d5 was played but now queen
to b7 just going after this
f7 pawn uh and here you don't really
have anything if rook captures on e5
for example pawn captures knight d5 yes
you can continue this
but you're down the exchange and you
don't really have anything anything to
do
it's just a one one sided game so
instead knight the e4 was played
kind of saying okay let's trade pawns
maybe i can grab this e
f two pawn uh but here uh gary just
played knight captures on f7 and he was
in this position almost 39
so one move before time control that van
gaal resigned the game
and uh well as there is nothing more uh
to be done here
what can you do nothing much uh you
can't win any pawns you can't
really move any pieces if you don't do
anything just moving the knife for
example knight d6 opens up a discovery
uh a discovery to the king maybe wins
the queen
and if you move the king there's really
no good square for you to move the king
this is taken by the knight this is
taken by the knight
you could go here but then you just run
into a nice knight h6
check and then for example uh we will
deliver a a very quick checkmate
so after knight captures on f7 uh
bunkhouse position
uh just you know wasn't playable and of
course he resigned here so it was a very
very interesting game
uh you know for for the entire game
it's hard to say if there was a move
where uh black could have played better
but
that's uh i mean that's usually how it
is with such uh such
perfectly played games with such deep
preparation
uh you know a few lesser moves not maybe
not the absolute top move but you played
the the second top move and then your
position just
uh uh deteriorates the to the point
where it's uh simply
uh you know uh uh uh untenable
uh so like i said after knight captures
on f7 he resigned and an excellent
victory for anish giri who
uh not uh well not no he doesn't join
the leaders but he is
very very close to joining the leaders
and we will discuss the standings as
this is only
uh the first game of uh day two that we
are showing
uh or rather of day that we're showing
so stay tuned we're gonna discuss the
standings uh in a little bit
uh so uh thank you for watching once
again i would like to thank
phillip gleason uh mr hoodie guy robert
smith pablo mohan and patrick solarz for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day